training starts early the first thing
puppy should know at this age is the
command come as they get older they are
introduced to chemical components used
in bomb-making the dogs are rewarded
each time they get it right eventually
they will be able to detect 12 different
chemical components found in explosives
all are odorless to humans
as soon as they walk in the door of
Moscow's Sheremetyevo Airport the sulla
muff dogs start their day job as
indefatigable sniffers
they have no boundaries is it the rush
rush leaping up wherever they can taking
in the smells signaling the trainer when
one is found no video le muchos a
portable signal here with episode K we
teach the dogs of following signals
first she sits then she barks and the
last signal is for the dog to show where
the smell comes from unlike German
Shepherds which are commonly used as
bomb sniffing dogs throughout the world
the Sula mouths hybrid searches without
prompting continuously give me a light
you should the German Shepherd will
never take its own initiative the hybrid
is never like this because it's more
independent and takes its own initiative
it has its own ideas of where to go and
what to smell and today is no different
except that on a routine sweep the dog
finds something and as rehearsed alerts
the trainer
a second dog confirms the discovery
officials start clearing the area as
bewildered passengers look on
after several tense minutes we learn
that this is just a drill
no one not even the trainer knows when
and where a planted item will be
incredibly inside this inconspicuous bag
were trace amounts of an explosive
chemical component amounts so slight
they were smaller than a grain of sand
and found by this dog
these dogs sense of smell is so acute
they can sniff through things like
luggage a sort of x-ray vision any
better it's a man-made machine that
doesn't break down